Well,
this selectors called virtue as a
necessity.
And
the reason I,
I gave it that title is because Virtue
Ethics,
morality isn't a field of study.
It's a mode of being upon which all
fields of study rest.
It's also a mode of being on which
everything you do in your life rests the
way you understand yourself or fail to
the way you understand other people or
fail to.
And more deeply than not what role it is
that you play in your life in the world.
And one of the things I've learned,
for example,
being a clinical psychologist who spent
thousands of hours helping people sort
out difficult problems,
is that lack of virtue makes people ill.
I'm not saying that my clients
themselves lack virtue.
I suppose some of them do and some of
them don't.
But to the degree that they're embedded
in a network of relationships where
virtue is fundamentally absent,
they're tortured and tormented and
they're unable to find firm ground and
that's not a biological problem.
Even though biologically fragile people
might be hurt more by a lack of virtue.
A lot of what you do in a real
relationship with people,
and at least to some degree of clinical
relationship is supposed to be real,
is provide a forum where people tell the
truth.
And that's hard because people don't
like to tell the truth.
Particular the truth is difficult.
It's difficult for a variety of reasons.
So when I first thought about this
lecture,
I had a slightly different title.
The title was virtue as an existential
necessity,
and that's a bit philosophical.
So I modified it,
but there was a reason for that because
the concept of virtue means to be
virtuous and existentialism is the study
of being right.
And I think that you can't really
understand what makes up virtue until
you modulator modify your notion of what
constitutes being.
This is a hard thing to do.
Modern people are fundamentally
materialistic and there's some utility
in that we're,
we're masters of material
transformation.
And the fact that we're materialist in
our scientific philosophies has made us
extremely powerful,
maybe too powerful for our morality,
extremely powerful from a technological
perspective,
but it's blinded as to certain things.
And I think one of the things that it's
really blinded us to is the nature of
our own being because we make the
assumption that the fundamental
constituent elements of reality,
our material,
we fail to notice that the fundamental
constituent elements of our own reality
are not material.
They're emotional,
they're motivational,
their dreams,
their visions,
their relationships with other people.
They're conscious,
they're dependent on consciousness and
self consciousness.
And we have absolutely no materialist
explanation whatsoever,
either for consciousness or self
consciousness.
And we don't deal well from a
materialistic perspective with the
qualities of being.
And everyone knows those qualities
exist.
I mean,
for most people,
there's nothing more real than their own
pain,
right?
Pain transcends rational argument in
that you can't argue yourself out of it.
It's just there and materialist or not.
There's very few people that are willing
to allow their,
the claim that their pain is merely a
napa phenomenal episode.
Nomina of some more fundamental material
process.
Pain is fundamental.
Consciousness is fundamental,
and I think that unless you understand
that you can't think properly about
virtue,
so I might start the discussion of
virtue with a discussion of Ba,
well,
what is human being look like?
Well,
the Buddhists say life is suffering.
That's the first fundamental Buddhist
dictum and I suppose a modern person
would tend to think of that as a very
pessimistic claim.
But I've found when I've shared that
information with my students,
once they understand what it means,
it's actually a relief because people
run around madly suffering away and all
of them inside their little shell think,
well,
there must be something wrong with me
because here I am suffering and you know
what I mean?
That that isn't how things are supposed
to be.
Well then you might say,
who says that's not the way things are
supposed to be?
The Buddhist say life is suffering so
that what that means is if you're not
suffering,
that's a good thing.
That's lucky.
That's fortunate.
That's not the way of the world.
That may be something to be grateful for
ecstatic about.
Even,
and of course in Christianity the
central symbol of Christianity is a
crucifix,
which is not a positive symbol in any
way.
It's a symbol of betrayal by friends,
opposition from the state and mortal
vulnerability.
It's about as powerful a symbolic
representation of the idea that life is
suffering as you can put together,
which is of course why the power of that
symbol extends across several thousand
years.
Judy is,
well,
I don't think it's going to come as a
shock to anybody in the audience that
Jews are acutely aware of the suffering
that's involved in life.
Okay,
so it's useful to know to understand
what it means that life is suffering.
It's a fundamental ontological truth.
It's a fundamental statement about the
nature of being,
and there's a reason for that.
It,
it's not incomprehensible.
It's perfectly comprehensible.
We're finite,
right?
We have a lifespan that's bounded
temporarily.
You're going to live maybe a hundred
years and that'll pretty much be it,
and then there's other forms of extreme
limitations that are imposed on you that
have very little to do with you.
They're arbitrary facts of being.
You're a certain height,
you're a certain weight,
you're a certain amount of attractive,
you're a certain amount of intelligent,
you're a certain amount of athletic,
you're a certain amount of mentally ill,
you're a certain amount of
predisposition to cancer.
And it's frequently the case that people
like to attribute those vulnerabilities
to some flaw in their own nature,
what they are instead.
Our conditions of existence,
human being is,
is predicated on a kind of fundamental
limitation in that we are what we are
and we're not other things.
And so that means inevitably that the
awareness of human being comes along
with suffering in life poses the
question
how to conduct yourself in the face of
suffering.
Not only yours but everyone else's.
And it's an inescapable question except
that maybe you're fortunate and you'll
have periods of time where something
absolutely horrible isn't helping
happening to you.
Now you,
you think about this because you might
think this is pessimistic,
but it's not pessimistic.
It's,
it's actually one of the most freeing
things that you can realize.
Maybe there's nothing particularly wrong
with you at the moment,
but there's a high probability that you
have a family member that has something
seriously wrong with them and there's a
very high probability that if you don't,
you will soon,
or maybe you'll have a partner that has
something serious wrong with them.
And,
and to know this frees you from the
false illusion that life can be
conducted without suffering suffering's
an integral part of the now why is that?
Well,
who knows?
It's a metaphysical question.
Would I have some ideas about that that
have helped me and that there are things
that I've read.
I read,
for example,
an old Jewish commentary about the
reason for creation there.
It's like a Zen Koan.
This idea of you take the uh,
um,
uh,
being with the classical attributes of
God,
omnipotence,
Omnipresence,
and omniscient.
All right?
It's a totality.
And the question is,
well,
what is it being with those attributes?
Lack and is limitation.
Okay.
And then you think,
well,
what's so important about limitation?
Well,
if you can be anything or do anything at
any time whatsoever,
there's no being,
because everything is one thing.
There's no differentiation between
things.
So something that's absolute and total
has no being.
It has to be parceled out into limited
being just,
and you know this because you'll all
play games.
You play video games,
you play games with other people.
You may play games you don't even know
you're playing.
And when you play those games,
you put,
you put limits on yourself,
you play by a set of rules.
And the reason you do that is when you
limit yourself arbitrarily,
in some ways whole new worlds of
possibility emerge.
And so there's a powerful metaphysical
idea that being is not possible without
limitation.
Okay,
so that's an interesting question.
That's an interesting idea.
So you say,
well what's the price you pay for being
the price you pay for being his
limitation and the price you pay for
limitation is suffering.
So the price you pay for being is
suffering.
So what's the problem with that?
Wrong
suffering makes people question the
validity of life,
right?
Every everyone does that.
If something terrible is happening to
you,
you're gonna wonder why you that.
That's for sure why not?
You might be a better question because
it's inevitable,
but you will wonder that why you and
you'll wonder,
well,
is it worth it?
Especially if what's happening to you is
terrible and prolonged.
Is it worth it?
That was the cars that you have to pay
for being justified itself and therefore
is being justifiable and everybody has
it asks and answers these questions.
In fact,
okay.
The process of asking and answering
those questions underlies everything you
do all the time because you're answering
when you act one answer,
which is yes being justifies itself and
you're answering a different way.
Sometimes when you act,
which is no being does not justify
itself and the question then might be
what happens when you answer one of
those two ways.
Well,
Don untangle this.
The first thing I want to do is to talk
to you about the antithesis of virtue
because it's always struck me that when
you're talking about something that
could conceivably be regarded as
optimistic,
it's difficult for people to
fundamentally believe you.
You know,
gave.
If I stood on stage and said,
well,
the purpose of life is to be happy you,
you might find out vaguely comforting,
but there's not a chance in the world
that you believe that if you have an
ounce of sense,
because if you lived,
you know that there will be periods of
time where happiness is not your state.
Okay?
And so there has to be more to life than
happiness because there'll be a lot of
your life that isn't happy.
Okay?
Solzhenitsyn,
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn who wrote the
book the Gulag Archipelago,
that was one of the axes that brought
down the thick tree of call me.
This utopian hasn't said over the idea
that human beings are made for
happiness.
He said that that's a philosophy that's
undermined by the first blow of the work
assigners Cudgel.
And what he meant by that was if you
find yourself in a particularly terrible
situation,
if you're in slaved,
for example,
by
okay
malevolent utopians and they're pushing
into a form of slavery and they're
beating you to attain their ends,
the idea that you're made for happiness
is not going to be of much comfort under
those circumstances.
And so social insistence point was your
weakened by your belief that life is for
happiness because that philosophy cannot
sustain any sustained challenge and you
will for sure encounters such as sustain
challenge.
Oh,
I don't think that modern people can
believe in virtue,
but not easily because it's virtue
sounds religious in a sense.
And we have real trouble whether we're
religious or not with religious
preconceptions because our scientific
forms of knowledge and our fundamental
materialism has really radically
undermined our ability to believe in any
transcendent being.
Okay.
But one thing that modern people can
believe in,
I think without much difficulty,
it all is evil.
Solzhenitsyn said,
for example,
that the most important event of the
20th century as far as he was concerned,
was the Nuremberg judgment.
And
you,
you may know,
you should know that after World War II,
a group of national socialists from
Germany who were deemed particularly
responsible for the absolute horrors of
the final solution and a mass factory
genocide that accompany,
that were put on trial
and
a standard defense for their actions
was,
well,
I was ordered to do it.
Okay.
And the Nuremberg decision denied human
beings regardless of their ethnicity or
national background or beliefs.
The legal right to use that as a defense
under certain limited circumstances.
And the argument was there are some
things that are so self evidently not
good,
not virtuous,
that if you engage in them,
you're existentially guilty.
You're guilty outside the bounds of your
culture.
There's a trans national and Trans
ethnic morality.
We don't know what it is,
but we know what it isn't.
It isn't pointless torture in genocide,
okay?
At minimum to be virtuous is to live
your life in such a way
that
the probability that you would engage in
such actions given the opportunity is
minimized.
Now people think,
well,
they're already doing that because if
they were in Nazi Germany,
they would have been rescue or not a
perpetrator,
but that's wrong.
You could take this audience and put
them back in 1939 or thereabouts and 90%
of you would,
95% of you,
99% of you would either be in the
perpetrator class or the going along
with the perpetrator class and you may
sit and believe that you'd be in the 1%
maybe you would because how do I know?
But that isn't how the historical facts
sort themselves out
and it turns out that it's not that
difficult generally to put people in a
situation,
normal people where they'll do something
that really doesn't look very good.
Those of you who are familiar with
psychology know about the milgram
experiments,
for example,
and know about the Zimbardo prison
experiment to take perfectly normal
college students and put them into a
situation that they know is a dramatic
forest they know isn't real.
Give some of them the power of prison
guards and make some of them,
some others arbitrarily into prisoners.
In three days,
you have to shut the whole experiment
down because of the prison guards have
turned into Nazis and they're enjoying
torturing the prisoners even though they
know whatever.
No means that they're innocent.
Yeah,
well that says something about the
manner in which people conduct their
existence.
They're very susceptible to mlevel into
action.
If you look at Genesis,
very old book and very influential book,
there's a strange sequence of events
that be falls,
Adam and Eve,
right?
Uh,
it's in two sentences.
That snake gives them an apple and that
wakes them up.
Well,
there's a good book by a
southern California primatologist that
was just published last year that
suggests that the reason that humans
have such great vision way better than
most animals except for raptors birds,
is because our visual systems were
designed to detect predatory snakes.
And the way she discovered that was by
comparing the populations of predatory
snakes around the world to the visual
acuity of the primate groups that lived
in those areas.
And what she found was essentially a one
to one correspondence our visual system,
which is the ability to see and to be
enlightened,
let say because enlightenment,
for example,
is associated with vision.
The snake gave that to us because we had
to pay attention to predatory things
that were after us for tens of millions
of years and fruit.
That's interesting.
We have color vision because we were
fruit eaters.
Our color vision is precisely evolved to
detect right fruit,
so that part of the stories,
right.
There's a story that involves women too,
but I'm not going to tell that one
today.
You have to be awake out smart women.
That's the story.
And so that's why they're tangled in
there with the Syrup and Sam the fruit.
And what happens when Adam and Eve wake
up?
Oh,
say it's this series of strange things.
The first thing that happens is that the
scales fall from their eyes so they can
see all of a,
they're awake in a way they weren't
before and the next thing that happens
is they realize they're naked.
Now,
one of the things that people,
okay
to have nightmares about his being naked
on a stage,
which is often why when you see people
they don't tell you anything.
They think because they don't only not
want to be physically naked,
they don't want to be metaphysically
naked either and they protect themselves
from the inquiring eyes of the audience.
No one likes to be naked on stage.
Why?
Well,
to be naked is to have your defenses
stripped from you.
When the Soviets wanted to really
torture the hell out of you at two
o'clock in the morning,
they'd stave in your door and then
they'd strip you and shave you when they
got you to prison because it's once you
were exposed in all your suffering,
catastrophe,
then you are much easier to torture.
To be naked.
To realize you're naked is to realize
that you're vulnerable.
You're vulnerable.
That's why Adam and eve immediately
cover themselves up,
right?
They realize they're naked,
they cover themselves up.
It's a story about culture.
Once people woke up and realize their
limitations,
their mortal limitations,
which is also their knowledge of death,
the first thing they do is cover
themselves up.
And the second thing that happens is
they know the difference between good
and evil,
and that's a strange thing.
It's not good and bad.
It's good and evil specifically.
It's also something that animals don't
know.
And I think I thought about this really
for 20 years.
What does that mean?
And then earlier this year,
I think I figured it out.
I think what it means is you don't know
how to torture people until you realize
that you're vulnerable.
As soon as your self conscious of your
own vulnerability,
then you can take what might only be a
predatory act,
say on the part of a wolf because of
wolf will bring down a moose or
something like that and eat it and drag
that out in two,
three months of artistic torturing.
And so that means that your recognition
of your own vulnerability immediately
allows you to determine what's evil.
Well,
so then you might ask yourself,
well,
under what conditions would you be
likely to manifest that drive?
Well,
I think that's easy to figure out if you
watch yourself,
you know,
if you watch yourself without
presupposition,
which is,
which means to watch yourself honestly,
or to watch yourself as if you're
someone you don't know because you don't
know yourself because you're too
complicated to know yourself anyway.
So you might as well just come right out
and know that.
I mean,
one of the things that's kind of useful
about recognizing your capacity for
evil,
if,
if you can do that without traumatizing
yourself,
is that it's the pathway to recognizing
your ability for good.
You don't get to one without the other
because you have no idea what your life
before you know how terrible you can be.
And not only that,
you won't take yourself sufficiently
serious,
seriously.
If you know you're a loaded weapon and
an unstable loaded weapon and you're
much more likely to pay attention to
what you do,
but that means you're not particularly
nice.
And it means that,
hey,
if you were given the opportunity,
maybe you would have been a Nazi prison
guard.
Now in genesis,
the first thing that happens after Adam
and eve wake up is they,
they,
they have two sons,
Cain and Abel and Cain who's ables
brother.
He doesn't get along very well with God.
Now,
I don't really care if you believe in
God because I don't know what people
mean when they say they believe in God
anyways,
but
the story goes that cane doesn't get
along very well with God.
And the reason for that is came,
keeps doing things and they don't work
his everything cane touches turns to
ash,
whereas his brother,
Abel,
God likes him.
God only knows why and everything goes
real well for a,
and so Kane Kane is kind of a failure
and enables a smashing success.
And not only is he successful at
everything he does,
but he's a good guy too,
which is really rude because if you're
really successful at things,
you should at least be wretched
interpersonally so that people can
forgive you.
So,
so kane takes this for,
you know,
a decade or two and then he's just had
it,
he's had it with God.
He thinks,
ah,
how can God make this sort of universe
where I'm,
you know,
breaking myself and half here and get
nowhere in my brother's doors open for
him,
left,
right and center.
So it goes and complains to God.
He says,
look what?
What's going on here?
What sort of reality did you conjure up
here?
Mabel has it good.
I'm having a miserable time.
Maybe you should do something about
that.
And you think that's pretty interesting.
You know that,
that cain would think that because you
have to ask yourself what sort of
presumption does cain house to assume
that the digital quality of his being is
attributable to God?
Because what Kane does,
it not instant is to make himself the
judge of being.
And I would say that you should be
cautious about making yourself the judge
of being,
because there's always the possibility
that there's a few things that you don't
know.
So go ahead and sort of lets paint in on
the secret.
He says,
look,
the fact that you're a suffering
miserably away actually isn't my fault.
It's your fault.
He says to Cain,
Sin Crouches at the door like a
predatory cat ready to jump on you.
But if you wanted to you could overcome
it.
This is not what cain wants to hear.
Take.
Cain wants to hear that he's an innocent
character and he has nothing to do with
his own misery and it's all God's fault
and God says instead,
straighten the hell up.
You know you could do it
and even though you know you could do
it,
you won't.
And so that that's that for cane.
Like,
I mean,
he was upset when he first went into the
discussion,
but after he got this little piece of
news that his suffering was to be laid
at his own doorstep,
then he's out of the realm of human.
And the story says his countenance.
Falls means he's angry and upset and the
first thing he does is run off and kill
Abel.
Why walks revenge?
Right.
Table was God's favorite and Cain has
already judged being and found it
wanting.
And the best way that he can express his
desire for revenge is to find someone
who's having a pretty good time of it
and to arbitrarily eliminate them.
Okay.
It might be of some interest to note
that one of keynes grandchildren is the
first person who makes weapons of war.
So that brilliant little story so long
ago,
associates the moral failings of the
resentful individual who's unwilling to
take responsibility for the nature of
their own being directly with atrocious
acts of social conflict.
Yes.
And that's another thing to know because
if you're going to be virtuous,
you have to take yourself seriously.
And if you start to understand that
you're networked with other people,
you're not one little dark among 7
billion year network with other people.
So you know a thousand people and they
know a thousand people and so you're two
people away from a million people and
three people away from a billion people.
You're in a causal network and all of
your actions matter.
Yeah.
Solzhenitsyn said there's many centers
of the universe says there are
individual consciousnesses,
and that's a very interesting way to
think and why can't it be that way?
We don't know anything about conscious
consciousness and it certainly seems to
be how it feels if you're one of those
conscious centers.
And so maybe it is that what you do
matters.
I think that often people come to the
conclusion that life is meaningless
because that's a better conclusion to
come to then the reverse because if life
is meaningless,
well then who cares what you do?
But if life is meaningful,
if what you do matters,
then everything you do matters and that
puts a terrible responsibility on the
individual and I think that people are
generally unwilling to bear that.
Okay,
so life is suffering.
What does that do to people?
Makes them resentful.
These are pitfalls of being so being has
a structure.
One of its fundamental structural
elements is suffering,
but suffering produces other.
Okay.
Characteristics of being resentment is a
characteristic of being.
People feel resentful when they believe
that they've been taken advantage of it
and maybe if you feel resentful,
it may be that you're being taken
advantage of.
It may also be that you should screw
your head on straight and look at things
properly and it may also be that you
should talk to somebody to find out if
you're
being taken advantage of or if you're
head just isn't screwed on straight,
but to talk to them.
Then you have to tell them the truth and
in order to tell them the truth,
you have to have practiced being honest
because if you haven't practiced being
honest,
then you're not going to have a friend
you can talk to.
And even if you did,
you won't be able to tell them what the
problem is and then they won't be able
to help you sort out whether or not
you're being taken advantage of or
whether you're a little bit insane.
Okay.
If you're resentful,
then maybe you have to tell the person
who's taking advantage of you that they
should stop doing that.
And maybe you have to tell them in a way
that will make them stop,
which is no easy thing.
Or maybe you're resentful because you're
a nasty little bit of the world and you
know you have a chip on your shoulder
and no matter what people do with you,
you're resentful,
in which case you have some internal
restructuring to do.
And you might ask,
well,
why should you do the restructuring?
And the answer to that is that well,
resentment along with hopelessness and
nihilism and all sorts of other moral
pitfalls puts you on the road to cruelty
and atrocity.
Misery loves company.
And if you feel that things are
fundamentally unjust and that the slings
and arrows of being are aimed
specifically at you,
why should you treat anyone else with
compassion or justice?
Because things are fundamentally unfair
and and even more deeply,
why shouldn't you conclude that things
should be eradicated?
Because fundamentally they're unfair.
I think that's what Hitler conclude.
I also think that's what stolen
concluded.
The evidence suggest that Stellan was
gearing up for the Third World War.
I mean,
he had hydrogen bombs,
he'd already killed 30 million people.
I mean he had his practice trials
and you know,
there's an old psychoanalytic idea and
the idea is if you can't understand the
motivations for the behavior,
look at the outcome and in further
motivations.
And so Hitler killed 100 million people.
If you include the whole Second World
War and God only knows how many Stalin
killed in my old killed more than
stellar.
Why?
Well of their cover story was utopia.
And I guess people belief that,
well,
why did look very utopian when all those
millions of people were dying?
I think all those people who
participated in those processes used
their rational utopianism as a cover
story for their willingness to
participate in the atrocity.
Because what they wanted to do was
participate in the atrocities.
They didn't give a damn about utopia.
Then you ask yourself,
well,
you know,
how much do you try to force the world
to behave according to your terms?
You know,
there Catholics have always had trouble
with rationality and modern people,
especially this sort of hyper atheists
that you hear from now and then.
Or you don't like that because they
believe that rationality is the highest
virtue.
And that's wrong.
I mean,
it's a terrible thing to say in a
university,
except maybe the university isn't here
to teach you to be rational.
Maybe it's here to teach you to be
virtuous and those aren't the same
thing.
And the rational person says,
well,
I understand and having understand
stood,
I impose an order and then I work to
make that imposed order or reality.
That's what every Indian log does it
what's whatever you Topian does.
It's convincing.
And I think the reason that people do
that is because they,
it's complicated.
Partly they want an explanation for
their Ba,
but more importantly than that,
they want to mask that covers up their
tendency to atrocity with the appearance
of virtue and most Utopian thinking.
It's of that sort.
Even though the mass can be very well
argued.
And you asked me why I believe that.
The reason I believe that it's because
we had a hundred years of it and that's
how it turned out.
One of the things that was terrible
about living in the Soviet Union was
that you couldn't suffer because things
were perfect.
So if you were suffering and you even
admitted it,
then you are instantly an enemy of the
state.
So if you're an idiot log your own
suffering makes you a heretic,
right?
Do you undermine the boat,
your belief and your own bloody system
by suffering while,
and that's fine if,
if your belief has stopped you from
suffering while more power to you.
But if you're still suffering a bit or a
lot or a tremendous amount,
then you can ask yourself,
maybe there's something I don't know.
Here's an existential exercise.
So in this is not rational,
we have say it.
Let's assume that virtues worth
pursuing.
And I say it's worth pursuing because a
virtuous path is the only path that
justifies being to itself as the
definition of virtue.
A virtuous pass path justifies being to
itself being as suffering.
So you need a justification for your
suffering.
So then you might ask yourself,
are there times in my life when I feel
that my suffering is justified?
And this is a good question.
And you could ask yourself the reverse
question two,
which is are there times in my life when
my my suffering is clearly not
justified?
And I could say,
well,
watch yourself for three weeks.
Just watch like,
like you don't know anything and see
when you're somewhere that justifies
itself.
Now I might say,
you might say,
well,
how do I know?
And I'd say,
okay,
well here,
here's some hints.
You're not self conscious.
You know,
it's not good to be self conscious,
right?
It loads on neuroticism.
It's a negative emotion.
I mean,
we think of it as a higher order
cognitive function,
but people find it unpleasant.
You tend to be self conscious when
you're false or shamed.
If you're deeply engaged in something,
your self consciousness disappears.
So engagement and something meaningful
seems to make selfconsciousness vantage.
It also makes time vanish,
right?
Because if you're doing something that
is intrinsically meaningful,
then the sense of passing time
disappears.
And so that temporal limitation that
plagues you vanishes.
And I could say maybe you're having a
miserable time of it and you only spend
2% of your waking hours in that
condition.
And maybe you don't even know when that
is,
but you could watch,
you could see,
and you could say,
hey look,
wow,
I spent 10 minutes there.
I hardly even noticed.
And I felt that the of my being
justified itself all.
Maybe you wouldn't say that to yourself,
but you could.
You could say that was worth it.
And then I could say,
Whoa,
practice that above all else.
Forget about everything else.
And then there,
there's an alternative exercise.
Pay attention and figure out when
absolutely you're being does not justify
itself.
That's even easier,
you know,
because that'll happen.
Whenever you do something that you
immediately regret or ashamed of or that
even more precisely makes you feel
disintegrated in devalued.
Nisha said,
people betray themselves for the sake of
their good name.
All the time.
You can feel this,
it seems to center in your solar plexus.
When you say something or do something
that is not virtuous,
then you will disintegrate and then
you're weak and you can feel that and
then you'll cover it up with bunch of
rattling arguments,
trying to convince yourself and other
people that what you were doing was
actually okay,
but you know,
and it's your rational arrogance and
authoritarianism that forces you not to
drop your stupid presuppositions and
just pay attention to what you're being
is revealing to you.
We don't think that way.
We don't think being reveals things.
It reveals things all the time.
We just don't pay any attention.
Why I think we don't want the
responsibility.
I really believe I've thought about this
for a long time.
I really believe that that's the case.
Here's a quote from the Tao Te Ching.
I have a great translation of this book.
It was written by louts loud see years
and years ago to one of the world's
classics of Literature.
The person who wrote this wasn't a
philosopher.
The person who wrote this was a master
of being.
That's a different thing cause if
philosopher thanks but a master being
doesn't think because thinking is a tool
and being is something that supersedes
any tool.
He said it is by she thing intellects
bright light that the sage remains at
one with his own self ceasing to be
aware of it.
By placing it behind detached.
He is unified with his external world by
being selfless.
He is fulfilled.
This is selfhood is assured.
I show my students in my maps of any
class.
Pinocchio.
Nokia is a very complicated story for
the Disney version in the previous
version.
It's got a deep mythological base and
one of the thing that's happened in
Pinell kill,
a lot of strange things happen that
people just swallow,
right?
There's a puppet.
It turns into human being and there's a
talking cat.
There's blue fairies,
there's stars,
there's whales that eat people,
and everyone's swallows that with the no
problem,
right?
You'll go to see Pinocchio.
You don't even notice that a puppet has
just gone into a whale and you know what
the hell is going on.
And the reason you don't notice that is
because it means something and you don't
know what it means,
but you know that it means something and
you're willing to ride on it weirdly
enough because it compromises your
rational principles completely.
It does.
These are religious experiences that
people have in movie theaters.
They suspend disbelief.
They go along with it.
It's not rational,
but they believed it.
And if someone says they lbu and saying,
that's not real,
you say to them,
you maybe you could shut up so I could
watch a movie.
All right?
You don't want their rationality inter
because it's,
it's the wrong time for it's the wrong
place for it.
Japan or wishes that his pep puppet
could become real is a very unlikely
wish,
which is something he says,
very unlikely.
It's unlikely to happen.
I think actually Jimminy cricket says
that to have that happen in Japan,
Oh,
has to wish on a star.
It was a strange idea.
Wistar is something that's partakes of
the divine.
You could say that if you look at the
night sky where you can really see it,
you know that,
right?
You look at the night sky and infinity
opens itself up before you,
and there's nothing to say except,
okay.
There's nothing to say and to wish on a
star is to put your eyes above the
horizon and to pick a transcendent point
and to wish for something to want for
something that's beyond the concreted
and immediate and to become virtuous
and,
and to not be a puppet is to aim at
something transcendent.
I could say,
well at least it's the absence of evil.
That something,
well,
maybe it's even more than that.
Maybe it's virtue in and of itself.
Okay.
There's a line in the sermon on the
mount.
It's a very strange sermon and the line
is take therefore no thought for the
morrow,
for the moral shell.
Take thought for the things of itself
sufficient unto the day is the evil
thereof.
It's a very strange
piece of advice.
It sounds completely impractical,
right?
I mean,
limit the focus of your consciousness to
the day and leave the worries alone.
Well,
it means something meditative.
I think when I do therapy with people
are trying to do this,
I don't think,
because I don't know if I do sometimes,
but I shouldn't.
I don't necessarily know what their
problem is or what they should do about
it,
but I can listen and if I listen and
maybe I learned this in part from Carl
Rogers writings,
if I listened,
then thoughts will occur to me.
I'm not thinking them.
It's different.
I'm letting the thoughts come up and I
do.
I tell my clients try to tell me the
truth and I'll try to listen without
being too much of a son of a bitch and
maybe you know,
maybe we can work something out and then
they'll say something to me and maybe
I'll think,
well that thing you said now in the
thing you said half an hour ago don't
seem to be,
they don't seem to be coherent.
So maybe you can straighten that out or
you know,
it seems more like I'm tracking what
they're saying and when I'm listening to
them I'm in the same place they are.
We know the neural mechanisms for that.
You are in the same place with someone
when you really listen to them and then
thoughts come up and I tell them what
they are and it's,
it's impersonal,
it's impersonal because I'm not trying
to get them to do anything particularly.
I'm just aiming maybe at helping them
figure out what's going on and having a
little bit less suffering and it's not
the imposition of an ideological
structure.
And the idea behind this particular
piece of advice is you can try this too.
You wake up in the morning and you
think,
okay,
this could be a good day,
whatever that means.
You don't know,
right what a good day is.
But maybe you've had a couple and
they're not so bad.
And so maybe you think you could have
another one but you don't know.
And you think,
okay,
you ask yourself,
and this is meditative.
What is it that I need to do today?
So that this would be a good day.
And your brain will tell you,
it'll say,
you know that build,
it's hiding under five pieces of paper
on your desk.
You should hall that sucker out and pay
it.
Or there's something you're avoiding
that makes you anxious that your brain
will pick on right away.
And it'll say you have to do these
whatever number of commitments today.
And if you do them,
then you fulfilled your obligations.
And the idea behind this piece of advice
is that if you fulfill your obligations
every day,
then you don't have to worry about the
future.
And that's a very interesting idea.
And it's predicated on the notion that
there's a wisdom inside people that
steeper than mere rationality,
and I believe that to be the case
because we're far older than mere
rationality from an evolutionary
perspective,
from any perspective you want.
We're deeper than rationality,
and we know old psychologists have
learned in the last 20 years that
rationality is bounded ridiculously and
all sorts of different ways.
It's not the master,
it's a servant and it's an unruly
servant.
Even though it can be a very powerful
one.
That totality of you,
the wisdom that's embodied in the
totality of you is far outstrips
rationality.
And if you listen to yourself and do the
difficult things that you're self tells
you to do,
the idea is you don't have to compute
the Utopian future because following
what it is that you tell yourself to do
every moment is the best path to
whatever the best outcome is.
That's a strange way of thinking because
if you're a utopian and a rationalist,
you already know what the right outcome
is and then you have to run around
pointing guns at people to make bloody
sure that they do the right thing so
that the outcome you've computed ochres
and that doesn't seem to work very well.
And so you see this idea in Taoism too.
The idea is to give up the end because
you don't know what it is and you and
you don't.
It's an admission of ignorance.
Where are you headed?
You don't know.
But that doesn't mean you shouldn't be
headed somewhere.
Follow your moral intuitions stopped
doing the things that make you feel
weak.
I'm not talking about following a moral
code,
although that can come into it.
If you really don't know what the hell
you're doing at all,
then following a moral code is a good
idea because it'll at least get the ball
rolling.
It's a form of apprenticeship.
So,
you know,
not doing the obviously bad things is a
form of discipline and it isn't the,
the,
the notion that I'm talking about now,
this is a different thing.
This is
bay attention to what's meaningful.
Cause you can see what that is.
You may find you're terrified of it
because everybody's got this little
secret wish I really love doing.
I don't know what it is.
It's different things for different
people,
but they're afraid to do it,
to really do it.
Because as soon as you do what you
really love,
then you expose your nakedness,
right?
You say,
this is what I'm really like.
Instead you just shove that under the
bed and you do something you don't care
about at all.
And then if people judge you,
it doesn't matter.
But the problem with that is you,
you,
there's no life there.
There's no force.
There's no you and without that,
the suffering will do you in and then
you'll become a bad person.
And that's not a good thing.
Yeah.
So you have to see what it is that you
find meaningful,
whatever that is,
and then you have to fight for it.
You have to fight against yourself.
You have to fight against other people
because what do they know about it?
And you have to fight against.
Nature may be even to stand up for what
it is that sustains you.
And that takes courage.
It also takes honesty,
partly because if you're not honest,
you can't trust your own intuition.
So this is an important thing.
You think about this and this is why
virtue is a necessity.
If you lie to yourself or to other
people,
then you
okay,
you corrupt the structure that you use
to interact with being.
You corrupt it.
And if you corrupt it,
then if you listen to it,
it will guide you the wrong way.
Or maybe it will be so corrupted,
you can't listen to it at all.
Then you have to listen to somebody else
and that might not be a good thing,
especially if you're already corrupted,
because then you'll listen to the person
who tells you to do what you really want
to do.
But won't admit it to yourself,
and that explains how Hitler found all
his followers.
They abandoned their own motive being it
made the bitter and resentful and empty
and hollow and weak and cruel,
and then they trained their leader to
tell them what they wanted to hear.
If you're honest,
which is painful,
you'll see that a lot of things you say
aren't real.
You'll see a lot of things that you do
make you weak.
You'll see that a lot of people you
associated with are probably not good
for you,
and then you have a lot of difficult
choices to make.
You can stop with the obvious lying
that'll clear things up for you a lot
and you can start communicating with
people.
One of the things I teach my clients is
if you're resentful,
say something about it.
Say something about it.
You tell the person,
look,
yeah,
what you asked me to do is making me
resentful.
Now,
if they're your wife or husband or
someone you love,
you should listen to them because they
might say,
well,
grow up.
Take your damn responsibility and leave
me alone.
And maybe,
and maybe they're right or maybe they're
a bit of a bully and you have to say,
quit pushing me around.
And then maybe you have to have an
argument with them,
an honest argument where you say,
look,
this is what's happening to me.
And they say,
look,
this is what's happening to me.
And you battle it out until you reach
some sort of settlement.
And then you don't have to be resentful
anymore.
And then you won't be mean and cruel,
vicious.
And you have to be honest in order to do
that.
Here's a,
here's a way of thinking about error.
You don't exactly know what you're
doing.
So how do you get to the point where you
know what you're doing?
I think follow your internal intuitions,
be honest about it and know what will
happen is a star will appear and then
guide you and the star is whatever makes
your life meaningful.
And maybe you'll take some tentative
steps in that direction and you'll get a
little ways and you'll think,
no,
that's wrong.
And then the thing that makes you like
meaningful will appear over there.
And then you take a few tentative steps
in that direction,
but as you step and walk towards these
things,
you change and as you change,
you get wiser.
And what happens is if you keep
following these things that make your
life meaningful,
then you correct yourself across time.
You see the thing there and that's wrong
and you see it there and that's wrong
and you see it there and that's wrong,
but you keep chasing it.
It as you chase it,
you move forward and as you move forward
and you do things and you learn from
your mistakes because you're honest and
you're watching,
you get wiser and wiser and the
consequence of all those mistakes is
you'll self correct the mistakes and 20
years down the road maybe you won't be
making so many mistakes.
They say it takes 10,000
hours to be an expert at something.
So you would need 10,000
hours of practice following what it is
that you need to follow.
I'm going to close with two things.
Okay?
I've come to the conclusion as a
consequence of studying the things I've
been telling you about,
that belief has a religious
substructure.
If you go all the way down into
someone's belief structure right to the
bottom,
what you find or religious
presuppositions,
they,
the person might not agree,
but I don't think that matters.
I think generally people don't know.
Here's an old religious presuppositions
older than Christianity.
It's supposed Christianity is the most
powerful proponent of this viewpoint.
There's a heaven and there's a hell and
you should live your life so that you
end up in one of them.
What's happened to Christianity is that
that's an afterlife thing.
I don't think it is an afterlife thing.
I think it's a now thing.
I see people who are in hell all the
time.
You can see them if you walked down
Bluer Street,
if I'm not kidding,
it's,
it's no joke.
If you walk by someone in Hell,
you can't look at them.
You won't look at them.
You'll,
you'll give them a wide berth.
And if you look at them and you really
look at them,
they'll either become aggressive or
ashamed because they do not want you to
see where they are because they don't
want to see where they are.
Yeah.
And by the same token,
heaven's a real place to and now and
then you're in it,
but you don't notice because you don't
believe in it.
There was an old Gospel,
Gnostic Gospel that was dug up in 1957
he gospel of Thomas and in the Gospel of
autonomous Christ says,
the Kingdom of Heaven is spread out on
the earth,
but men do not see it.
And I don't think that's a metaphor or,
or maybe it is a metaphor,
it's a deep metaphor.
It means that life,
human life is very expensive and we live
in the middle.
It's kind of a mediocre middle often.
And at one extreme there's a hell and
the other extreme is heaven.
And we bounced back and forth between
them without really noticing.
And I could say,
well here,
here's something to consider.
If the things you're doing are landing,
you inhale stop.
Unless you want to be there.
And you know,
if you think you,
all you have to do is think about your
life over the last year,
you,
you can be certain that you can call to
mind times when you would have rather
that did not happen.
And so the lesson from that is clear.
Don't set up those conditions anymore.
And by the same token,
if you watch yourself,
you can tell when you're where you want
to be.
And I could say,
well,
if you're where you want to be and
that's really the right place,
then all you should ever do is practice
to be there.
The Kingdom of Heaven is spread out on
the earth,
but men do not see it.
So this is what I would say about
virtue.
Virtue first is the attempt to see that
heaven and it's a questioning thing.
And it,
I'm not saying it's the same for
everyone.
I don't believe that at all because
people are individuals just to see it.
And the second thing is to attempt to
live in it.
And I truly believe,
I truly believe that there is nothing
that you can do that's better for being
not only for yourself,
but for everyone that you interact with.
None of you know your potential.
People are amazing creatures that you
know that people can be a Biz mully
awful,
but they can be as remarkably good as
they are.
Uh,
uh,
Bismilaahi awful.
I think it's rare,
but it's not beyond the realm of
possibility.
What's a human possibility?
Well,
no one knows.
Maybe it's,
it's near infinite.
We know nothing about our own being or
about our relationship with the totality
of things.
We may occupy a more important place
than we all think and the consequences
of our actions,
our virtues or our lack thereof.
Echo may echo far beyond what we want to
believe.
So I would say try to find out what's
good for you.
Just watch,
don't listen to anybody else.
Or maybe you should.
Maybe they'll give you some hints,
you know,
but you've got to sort it out for
yourself.
And when you find out what's good for
you and what isn't,
do the things that are good for you.
Until you like being alive and to,
until you're thrilled to be alive.
Let's see what happens.
And I would also suggest there's nothing
you could possibly do that will be more
profound and useful than that.
That's all
[inaudible].